hey guys Peter Brown here with the game
spot news update co-creator of the
assassins creed franchise Jade Raymond
has just announced that she's opening
motive a new studio under electronic
arts Raymond's new steel will be opening
in Montreal Canada where she will be
working in close quarters with the
Bioware team suggesting that motive
could have a hand in Mass Effect
Andromeda I'm happy to announce that i'm
joining Electronic Arts and opening
motive a new development studio in my
hometown of Montreal Canada she
announced motive will be incubating
entirely new IP taking on some amazing
projects including the new star wars
game from former uncharted writer Amy
Hennig and developed by dead space
studio visceral I've known ami for years
and have admired her work on the
uncharted games I'm thrilled that the
first big project that we will work on
in Montreal will have a me as creative
director an opportunity to work with her
in the visceral team and to play in the
Star Wars universe is once-in-a-lifetime
stuff little is known about visceral and
henning Star Wars games but according to
voice actor nolan north who voiced
nathan drake in the Uncharted series the
game will bear similarities to Star Wars
1313 are you looking forward to another
shot play Star Wars 1313 or something
like it and you think Amy Hennig and
Jade Raymond are heading in the right
direction let us know in the comments
below and stay tuned to gamespot for
more gaming news
you